bonjour bienvenue chez respecte
[Musique]
chère que deux amis de longue date
romain et Cyril ont implanté leur
brasserie éco-responsable fin 2020 dans
ce local de près de 150 mètres carrés il
produiront d'ici la fin de l'année près
de 300 hectolitres à ce jour les ivinois
proposent leurs clients en collaborant
avec des producteurs locaux on a une
blanche basilic citron vert donc qui va
être la bière une bière très légère qui
se boit bien très rafraîchissante on va
avoir notre best-seller c'est la blonde
après effectivement on a deux l'ombrés
de l'ail pied une on a des bières un
petit peu plus atypiques comme une
ambrée fumée on a également une bière
qui est faite avec de l'écorce d'orange
amère qui s'appelle la jamais contente
et on a une triple au miel c'est une
bière triple donc on va dire assez forte
elle est à 8h30 et qui est faite avec un
miel de printemps miel qui vient du
Vexin miel plusieurs fois médaillé
franchement ça donne une saveur
exceptionnelle à la bière pour compléter
leur offre les deux passionnés de bière
se sont lancés cette année dans une
boisson sans alcool ils ont créé leur
limonade les commercialise ce nouveau
produit depuis trois mois dans leur
local et salle de spectacle les
épiceries fines et les cinémas des on
voulait augmenter notre notre gamme de
produits et en fait on voulait une
segmentation sans alcool et aujourd'hui
la bière sans alcool pour nous c'est
encore un peu compliqué c'est un peu
prématuré donc en fait on s'est dit
qu'on allait faire la limonade voilà
sans alcool pour à la fois les grands et
les petits et en plus fabriquer la
limonade en fait ne nécessite pas
d'investissement matériel autre que les
matières premières ont étiquettes
bouteille transparente etc donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on sait faire au total
les brasseurs ont écoulé plus de 50
cartons de cette nouvelle limonade vendu
un peu plus de 2,50 € avec ce nouveau
succès les deux compères espéragrandir
leur local dans les prochains mois et
recrutés du personnel mais ils nous
l'ont assuré pas de pression